imagine a world where everything you see
is filtered designed specifically to
your unique preferences evolving
intuitively to your desires before they
even form in your own mind
or a world where you can be anywhere
anyone without leaving your bedroom
well what if this world
sucks oh my God
are we gonna be able to live without
these devices how is this going to
change how we experience space and how
will these virtual Dimensions affect our
physical world
[Music]
a portion of this video is sponsored by
Wayfair
virtual reality is the promise of a
fully immersive interconnected universe
that transcends physical limitations a
world Unbound by gravity material
limitations or cost sounds kind of like
the dream right augmented reality is
even more interesting because it can
enhance our physical world by overlaying
digital information and objects on top
of our real world both of these could
completely transform all areas of life
including how we use our environments
now we can all be in the same space but
have a completely subjective experience
of that space But why does all of this
still feel so far from reality
foreign
public transit is this unique in between
space where we can physically exist in a
communal space but mentally be immersed
in our personal world it's also a
universal experience so it's kind
best way to observe cultural changes but
there's something about this image
that's a little bit unsettling
and it might have something to do with
ambiguity according to Claude Levy
Strauss the facial disguise temporarily
eliminates from social intercourse the
part of the body which reveals personal
feelings and attitudes the reason why
masks can be creepy even if it's neutral
or happy might have something to do with
the fact that it hides the emotions or
intentions of the person underneath I
don't know if this person is crying or
glaring at me and this weird
psychological phenomenon might be why
Apple spent millions of dollars
developing this feature called eyesight
which at first seems like a completely
useless feature it basically allows
people to see an actual live simulation
of your eyes with data from the internal
infrared cameras to pry to capture your
eye movement and facial expressions the
data is then fed to a machine learning
algorithm that combines it with your own
unique digital Persona using the
front-facing truth of the camera all of
this Tech and r d just so that you can
see if somebody's looking directly at
you or if they're immersed in their VR
space and this connection between what's
happening behind your glasses and your
surroundings could be one of the key
steps to mass adoption and as we get
more comfortable wearing these devices
it's going to unlock a whole new world
that straddles between the physical and
the digital
[Music]
historically architecture used
programming diagrams to Define distinct
separate spaces as we get into more
post-modern architecture we start to get
a bleeding of different programs
creating these in-between spaces VR and
AR allow us to merge all of this and
create multiple spaces within one
physical space and not just that each
person could have a totally different
experience of that space basically
everything we know about
three-dimensional space goes out the
door and we get what matsuda calls the
subjective space where everyone can be
in the same environment and experience
different realities someone sitting just
next to you on the bus will see a
completely different city curated to
their personal tastes and interests you
can be in your digital bedroom while
you're physically in a cubicle or an
airplane or a prison song you can also
be in a museum or a concert hall or an
aquarium or a basketball court or pool
or school or a library
there's something fundamentally human
about wanting to share a communal
physical experience with other people
Studies have found that going through a
shared experience just by being in the
same space can intensify that experience
even if there's no verbal exchange and
even if it's just with strangers in this
one study from Yale University students
were given chocolate either
simultaneously with another participant
or alone despite both chocolates being
identical students reported the
chocolates tasting better when they ate
it with the other person in the room
and that's why even if we don't need to
we like going to a library or a coffee
shop we like being in the same space and
the presence of other people these are
some of the moments from the light ship
Summit conference in 2022. the graphics
are still kind of at a rudimentary level
but it's an example of how virtual
content could mesh with the physical
world the goal was to create a local
experience that could only exist in this
specific location and in order to do
this they overlay the virtual space on
top of the existing space using
traditional architectural techniques
like plans sections 3D modeling as well
as new VR tools to draw these cute
little elements that interact with the
people and the space and the result is a
spatial experience where the digital
fabric is woven into the architecture of
this conference venue most of this is
experience through the phone like this
but once headsets become a part of our
daily routines we're going to have a
much more seamless immersive experience
so I think rather than subjective space
Maybe brick and mortar stores are going
to try to capitalize on this innate
desire to be in the same space and try
to create a hyper local experience that
can only be experienced at their stores
we've seen how stores have transformed
since the rise of Instagram with more
and more of these themed stores popping
up maybe we'll be seeing an amplified
version of this where stores combine AR
and their physical space to create a
unique experience that you can't
replicate anywhere else
what is this
oh it's time to talk about Wayfair you
probably know of Wayfair as a website
where you can buy affordable and chic
furniture but did you know that they
also have an educational YouTube channel
a style is born as their new series
where they discuss how and why certain
Styles came to be it's really well
produced really well researched and I
love how they break down the history of
that style from the social and economic
conditions and why it's making a
comeback and I think when you understand
the context behind something you can
really appreciate it a lot more Beyond
just the Aesthetics of it anyways I
would highly recommend you check out
their episode on how brutalism influence
interior design I personally love
brutalism but it's also quite
controversial
people either love it or hate it but
what's certain is that it's spread all
over the world and became a trend in
itself so yeah check it out and go and
subscribe to their Channel I'll include
the link in the description
but what happens when we leave the
public realm and into our homes the
design of homes can be one of the best
ways to observe the changes in culture
or lifestyle it went from this to this
to this as the TVs went from this to
this to this in fact TV has been the
focal point of our living rooms for
decades we Orient things around the TV
because it's not just entertainment
as weird as it is it's kind of a passive
bonding experience but what if and this
is a huge what if
TVs become obsolete imagine your homes
without TVs
everyone plugs into their own
entertainment or if you want to have a
shared viewing experience plug into a
device that syncs all of your movies we
might lay things out specifically for
talking or hanging out maybe we can
bring back conversation pits which could
even be covered when it's not being used
giving you even more space for VR
activities but since this requires more
floor space we can get a ryzen modular
furniture that could be arranged in
multiple ways maybe we'll start getting
more of this than this or we could start
to adopt more movable or sliding walls
to adjust the space for VR use
foreign
ERS one that deals with the physical
layer and the other on the digital
and since digital design can be much
more cost effective and resource
efficient than constructing physical
structures we can potentially create
safer more accessible and more
aesthetically pleasing spaces with the
same budget this could even prioritize
initiatives for Street beautification
which often ranks very low in budgetary
considerations lower income communities
could get the same kind of aesthetic
treatment as wealthier neighborhoods
maybe more green spaces more
architectural diversity or streets lined
with trees
but what about this experience
being in nature has a whole lot of
health benefits and one of the reasons
is because it's a very holistic
multi-sensory experience in fact tactile
stimulation has been linked to
improvements in memory and learning
spatial awareness and even emotional
connection but most of our current world
is created considering only one of the
five senses sight
[Music]
yuhani plasma is the author of eyes of
the skin also one of my favorite books
and he writes the suppression of other
sensory Realms has led to an
impoverishment of our environment
causing a feeling of Detachment and
alienation these intangible elements are
very easily neglected especially in the
face of rabbit change but these are the
things that can enrich our experiences
it's hard for me to not imagine a
dystopian future where trees just look
like trees but don't smell or sound or
move like them or you step into a cabin
but you don't smell the cedar you can't
feel the grains of wood or the concrete
on your skin maybe we won't even notice
what's missing because we forgot what it
feels like or these real tactile
experiences are reserved only for
certain people or certain neighborhoods
but what if in instead of creating
completely new environments it's more
about filling in the gaps
[Music]
I'd imagine that filling in a tree
between two existing trees would require
a lot less computational power than
creating it from scratch but it could
also increase the believability of
virtual objects by sitting between the
real objects our brains also have a
tendency to fill in the gaps so it could
read the virtual elements as real it
could even apply to architectural
details one of the mandates of modernism
which was a reaction to the Bose Arts
Movement was to democratize architecture
by stripping it of all of its ornaments
because ornamentation was expensive but
let's be honest maybe other than
Architects I think most people would
pick this over this with ar we could
bring back delicate ornamentation maybe
it could even change how we detail
certain elements to be better equipped
for ER this idea of filling in the gaps
it could even happen at the macro level
at the city scale in typical City grids
we have our front streets and our back
alleys which are usually the leftover
space designers have attempted to design
the back alleys with not a huge amount
of success but with the help of AR maybe
we can actually design and program the
alleys or parking lots with very little
cost and we can actually start to use
these leftover spaces the digital divide
suggests that with these new
technologies we're gonna see an even
bigger gap between the rich and poor
those who can afford to will have access
to more information and also a better
spatial experience where the wealthy can
buy spaces with less ads and the they're
going to have a more comfortable and
accessible AR space but maybe with the
right guidance and strategic
implementation we could actually close
that Gap and we could use Virtual
content to increase the aesthetic
standards and create environments that
are beautiful and inclusive and engaging
and layer all at the same time
foreign
[Music]
right now a very select few in society
shape our environments just due to the
sheer amount of training involved but in
the digital world where rigorous
standards like building codes don't have
to apply it opens the doors for more
people from all backgrounds to influence
the visual fabric of our communities but
who knows maybe our virtual experiences
will be so cool that we forget about our
physical world all together
thank you
what do you guys think about all these
Dimensions let me know in the comments
also we have a Discord community and a
newsletter I'll leave the links in the
description and with that I'll see you
in the next video over here
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign